changement de décor lorsque la vérité
dérange faut-il lui préférer l'illusion
qui réconforte pour limiter les pouvoirs
de l'état faut-il autre question s'en
remettre à l'état ou encore y at il une
vertu de l'oubli voilà c'est loin d'être
évident j'en conviens je vous ai donné
en vrac comme ça trois des sujets de
philo proposer aux futurs bacheliers ce
matin ils étaient plus de 400 milles à
plancher sur la première épreuve du bac
88 ce soir l'angoissent des potaches et
plus ou moins retombées ça change de
camp et c'est au tour des correcteurs
d'afficher une certaine fébrilité
ils sont plus de 2000 sur la sellette
avec en toile de fond tenez vous bien
quatre cent quarante mille copies un
véritable pensum reportage chantal
kimmerlin un joli paquet cadeau pour
plus de 2000 correcteurs 200 copies de
philosophie à corriger avant le 4
juillet si le nombre de copies augmente
chaque année avec le nombre d'élèves le
moral des profs est lui plutôt à la
baisse
niveau général oblige la vraie question
comment ce conte ce sont des copies où
on voit 20 fautes par page et pire
peut-être des copies ou où la pensée
devient inintelligible parce que la
langue qui est censée la porte et qui
est censé l'exprimer est déficiente et
tellement déficiente que la pensée se
perd ça veut dire qu'on corrige les
copies différemment aujourd'hui qu'il ya
cinq ou dix ans eut bien sûr je crois
que tous les correcteurs vous le diront
nous mettons 10,12 à des copies que nous
trouvons très inférieur aux exigences
légitimes d'une épreuve
ce qui compte c'est la capacité à
produire une réflexion personnelle et
pertinents il y avait une retraite ce
serait où trois recettes selon la
formule fameuse la première c'est la
carte et la seconde c'est la clarté la
troisième c'est la clarté mais le sort
en est jeté les copies ont tout ce soir
un correcteur il n'est plus temps de
laisser s'installer le doute et les
regrets qui peut sans dormir tranquille
ce soir
le sage celui qui a compris parce qu'il
a bien philosopher peut-être que certes
le baccalauréat est important mais
que le plus important n'est pas là je
crois qu'en l'occurrence ils ne
dormiront pas tranquille bien sûr il que
tant qu'il faut qu'il continue à
philosopher